I'm Kay Warren the executive director of
the HIV aids initiative at Saddleback
Church i was born in San Diego so I'm a
California girl lived there my whole
life except for two years when we were
in seminary in Fort Worth I think being
on the west coast has definitely shaped
me to experience life from a perspective
of I know we originate ideas at least we
like to think we originate ideas on the
west coast and seems like we're always a
little bit ahead of the curve my parents
had a tremendous influence on me my dad
was a pastor in small churches my mom
was the quintessential pastor's wife and
I think I learned about service from
them they not only taught me to love God
but they really showed me how to live a
life of service when I was a little girl
there really weren't that many women
that I knew of who worked outside the
home as they would say my mom didn't
ever work outside the home when she had
kids most of the women and the churches
that I grew up in so I I didn't ever
really have a career goal for myself I
always wanted to be a wife and a mom I
studied to be a home act teacher got my
degree in home economics because at one
point Rick and I thought we were going
to be missionaries somewhere around the
world and I thought what a great great
thing you know home economics that was a
very practical major is it turns out we
ended up in you know affluent Orange
County California where nobody cares at
all whether I can cook or sew or find
the best price of chicken I mean who
cares it seems they're relevant but at
the time it seemed like something good
to do
you